So, user research is the umbrella name for
a wide array of techniques you can use to
just understand who your users are with the
goal being to learn to design and develop better
products. It can run from, in lab testing,
where you have head-mounted tracking equipment and all kinds
of sensors to going to field studies where you
hop on airplanes and go to all the corners
of the globe. To watching your logs, where you're getting
data from millions of users. And kind of trying to
understand what they're doing and how you can do it
better. Or you can do it much more cheaply, much more
quickly. And because every little bit that you do, to
kind of better understand your users is going to be tremendously
valuable to you. So you can do things like just
talking to a handful of people. But taking printouts or drawings
of what you think you're going to build and putting it
in front of people and getting their responses to it. Like
lots of little things can help you tease away little bits
of information about who your users are and how you can
better work for them. We all think we know ourselves
pretty well, so naturally if you just kind of base on
what you know about yourself and what you want, you'll build
a product that hopefully satisfies at least you. But you also
cover so many experiences, so many preconceptions, so many assumptions, about
what this project should be, how it should work, built on
everything you've gone through with other products before in your life.
You don't share that with all of your users and you
may not even share the same goals for this product with
your users. If you want to build something that's really successful, you
need to understand them, where they're coming from, where they're trying
to go. And then you can build a product that completes that
story for them. Even if time is short and you just
have to make a decision right now and you can't take
the time to go out and talk to other people, just
by thinking about that persona, inventing it. Takes you out of
your own head and starts you thinking about somebody else. So
it's better to kind of build for that other, even if
it's not based on hard data than to just bias towards
your own needs. This was awhile back but I was working on
a product for, kind of, bloggers who weren't
bloggers yet. Kind of non-expert bloggers to create posts
and start sharing things and I wasn't interested
in blogging as a product at all. So it
was very much that I had to kind of
think about users who strongly weren't me. And I
remember in particular there was this desire from
users that surprised me that they just wanted to
record audio for their blogs. They didn't even want to sit down and
write it, they want to kind of compose these things, they want to be able
to be out and to go and just. You speak into their phone
and [SOUND] pop up comes the entry. It's a kind of thing that
I would of never thought about if I had only referred like what
I would of expected out of that product. I would of assumed, oh,
I want to spend time crafting this and typing this thing. But its
turned out to be one of the most satisfying parts of that product
for users and something that was also a differentiator between
other that and other products that were on the market.